this explosion of women going in into
the entrepreneurial field if you will
are onto the entrepreneurial ocean and
brave Ling sail it bravely sailing forth
to create their own businesses and their
own products and we're not I'm not
talking just about women you know with
with with rich education and many many
you know sort of economic assets I'm
talking about women at all points along
the social spectrum who are you know
building beauty shops setting up setting
up small schools for their kids opening
up new telecommunications ventures
creating a beauty company to sell to a
larger beauty corporation women doing
astounding things all over the map for a
variety of reasons it's not the least of
which is being their own boss and having
control of their time but women are now
starting in this country more businesses
than men by some measure and that's
interesting and exciting and different
than in the past